bonsoir nous sommes le mercredi 14 14
octobre merci de nous retrouver pour
cette nouvelle édition du 78 le journal
on commence tout de suite avec les
titres de votre actualité
locale hier mardi les élus de la
majorité de 50 ans en yeline dévoilent
les résultats de plusieurs audits
internes et les accusations contre
l'ancienne équipe dirigeante de e était
lourde aujourd'hui ils répondent en
dénonçant la manière mais aussi le fond
de certains dossiers les maires des
Yvelines se réunissit aujourd'hui à
portmley comme chaque année au programme
de cette université la diminution des
dotations de l'État les inquiétudes que
cela
engendre journée nationale du refus de
la misère ce samedi 17 octobre ATD
carmonde organise un rassemblement
public à plaisir à cette occasion les
détails avec Alain avet responsable
local de l'association dans les CINES
invité de cette édition et nous vous en
parlions il y a 10 jours les salariés
d'une entreprise de plaisir se
mobilisaient pour récolter 150000 €
somme nécessaire à une opération qui
aurait pu sauver Christophe leur
collègue salariés touché par un cancert
le 7 octobre dernier Christophe est
malheureusement décédé avant une
éventuelle transplantation les 30000 €
déjà récolté par les salariés iront à sa
famille et à l'association imagine for
Margot qui soutient la lutte contre le
cancer
infanti après avoir passé devant la
presse hier en revue les résultats de C
audits commandés l'an dernier président
et vice-président de saquanttin en yvine
ont eu droit aujourd'hui à la réponse
des principaux intéressés la majorité
accuse ses prédécesseurs de gauche
d'avoir mal géré les finances voire même
d'avoir commis plusieurs erreurs les
précisions de Wilfred Richy et Mélanie
poquet je veux bien avoir un vrai débat
mais avec des vrais documents sur
qu'est-ce qui reprocher sur sur sur sur
quel élément et pas à partir de graphiqu
qui don qu'un sens pas sourcé pas
chiffré qui sur lequel on peut faire
dire tout et n'importe quoi agacé
l'opposition socialiste et communiste
depuis hier et cette conférence de
presse organisée par le Président de la
Communauté d'Agglomération Michel logier
et son premier adjoint en charge des
affaires économiques Jean-Michel
Fourgous il faut dire que les
accusations qui pèsent sur eux et qui
seraient basé sur les analyses de cinq
cabinets d'audit sont lourdes mauvaise
gestion qui expliquerait un déficit de
400 millions d'euros et surtout train de
vie dispendieux et recrutement partisan
de la diffamation on va mettre ça dans
les mains dans les mains d'un d'un
avocat moi je suis non non on peut pas
se laisser mettre en cause et diffamé
comme ça à tout vaa de façon générale en
arrivant à la tête de l'agglomération la
nouvelle majorité de Saint Quentin
enveline avait entrepris un bilan du
travail mené par ses prédécesseurs si
les élus aujourd'hui passés dans
l'opposition se disent prêts à
poursuivre en justice ceux qui auraient
été coupable d'abus elle attend des
preuves moment donné on s'est demandé si
c'était une conférence de presse de
Michel logier en tant que président
d'aglo aussi il s'agissait d'une
conférence de presse partisane de de
Valérie pécr ou en plus il y avait son
son porte-parole qui était là ou d'un
parti politique ce qui est pas du tout
la la même chose les deux sont légitimes
mais c'est pas la même chose mais là en
l'occurrence on a l'impression qu'il y a
utilisation des moyens de
l'agglomération à des fins politiques au
profit d'une famille politique dans une
période électorale avant le scrutin des
régionales les élus se retrouveront lors
du prochain conseil communautaire et la
séance risque d'être agitée le mois
dernier déjà les tensions étaient vives
autour des avantages concédés par
l'ancienne majorité pour l'obtention de
la rider Cup de golf en
2018 politique toujours aujourd'hui à
portmle se tenait l'Université des
mairies les maires des ilines étaient
invités à rencontrer les partenaires
économiques du quotidien autour de table
ronde des ateliers ou encore des
conférences pour cette 9e édition était
présent sur l'événement le président du
Sénat Gérard Larcher et le président du
conseil départemental Pierre Bédier qui
ont évoqué notamment la baisse des
dotations de l'État William l était sur
sur
place élus cadres et agents territoriaux
les représentants yvelinois ont répondu
présent aujourd'hui à l'université des
mairies de portmly un événement qui
rassemblait les acteurs économiques du
territoire et les élus l'occasion
également pour eux d'échanger sur les
Grand défis à venir au cœur des
discussions du jour la baisse des
dotations de l'État aux collectivités
territoriales le département des évines
va perdre 120 millions d'euros en 3 ans
la communauté d'agglomération de 50 ans
va perdre 15 millions d'euros en 3 ans
la ville de Monti va va perdre plus de 4
millions en 3 ans donc aujourd'hui on
est tous là pour être solidaire et et
pour savoir comment enrayer un petit peu
ces choses-là le président du conseil
départemental et le président du Sénat
étent présent et ont insisté
particulièrement sur ces baisses de
dotation illégitime pour Pierre Bédier
qui estime que l'organisation
institutionnelle française n'a pas à
payer la dette du système social
français
le problème il est au niveau de notre
système social il est au niveau de ce
qu'on appelle l'État providence je suis
en train de vous dire qu'il faut pas
faire de la solidarité à crédit sur les
générations futures les 2100 milliards
que nous devons nous les devons à cause
de notre dépense social nous venons
d'apprendre une décision unilatérale de
l'État pour la fin 2017 qui est un coût
d'un milliard 6 de plus sur la fonction
publique territoriale dans une
revalorisation salariale donc l'état
peut pas avoir de langage d'un côté
demander aux
collectivités de réduire leur frais de
fonctionnement et en même temps les
alourdir par des décisions unilatérales
les efforts demandés aux collectivités
seraient d'après les élus trop
importants pour les maires les baisses
de dotation au commune conduirait
inévitablement à une augmentation des
taxes locales et une diminution des
prestations
sociales le 6 octobre dernier le
ministre de la Ville Patrick canner
signé un contrat de ville avec 550 ans
en iveline et plus de 32 acteurs dont
Manille Lamo la commune est notamment
concernée avec le quartier du Buisson
anciennement classé quartier prioritaire
il est dorénavant en veille active plus
d'explications avec Mélanie
poquet c'est notamment parce que le
revenu médian est plus élevé que le
critères fixés par l'État que le buisson
n'est plus quartier prioritaire mais la
géographie prioritaire va s'effacer
petit à petit avec le placement du
quartier en veille active jusqu'en 2020
c'est-à-dire un maintien des politiques
de droit commun le droit commun
on peut considérer que c'est la
Prévention Spécialisée on peut
considérer que ce sont des effectifs de
gendarmerie que ce sont également des
effectifs de l'éducation nationale
euh et puis aussi des actions qui
peuvent concerner les transports par
exemple pour la ville pour continuer de
participer au désenclavement du quartier
pour lutter contre l'enclavement de
nouveaux transports ont été développés
en collaboration avec la casquie et le
STIF avec plus de 3700 habitants le
quartier du Buisson regroupe près de 40
% de la population de la commune de
Manille et amau une population avec des
familles monoparentales touché par le
chômage des jeunes ou le décrochage
scolaire certains de nos partenaires
profitent du fait qu'on arrive en vaille
active pour dire ben on arrête puisque
de toute façon vous n'êtes plus en
contrat de ville ce qu'il n'arrivve pas
à saisir je pense qu' c'est juste parce
qu'il n'arrive pas à le saisir parce que
c'est nouveau
mais il ils ne comprennent pas que nous
sommes encore aujourd'hui signataire du
contrat de ville toutes ces
problématiques sont rassemblées en six
objectifs actés avec la signature le 6
octobre dernier du contrat de ville
intercommunale avec le ministre de la
Ville économie à présent lors de son
conseil municipal ce lundi 28 septembre
la municipalité de manilamo s'est
déclaré hors tafta le tafta c'est le
partenariat transatlantique de commerce
et d'investissement entre l'Union
européenne et les États-Unis dont le but
est d'instituer une zone de libre
échange et d'investissement mais aussi
de créer un marché commun aux règles
simplifiées la municipalité demande
entre autres l'arrêt des négociation
mais aussi la diffusion publique des
textes et l'ouverture d'un débat
national une prise de position
symbolique écoutez le maire de manie
lamoau Bertrand Ouillon on espère que ça
ne restera que symbolique puisque
derrière on veut absolument avoir
connaissance de l'ensemble de ces textes
et qu'il y ait un véritable débat
citoyen en France par rapport à ces
élémentslà il est hors de question pour
nous en tant qu'élu parce que voilà on a
été élu par la population il est hors de
question que des accords ou des
négociations secrète entre grands
commerçants mettent à néant tous les
services publics qui permettent chez
nous d'avoir un un minimum d'équité
aussi entre entre les habitants et nous
passons maintenant à notre entretien
nous accueillons Alain av responsable
local de l'association ATD carmonde pour
nous parler parler de la Journée
mondiale du refus de la misère bonsoir à
vous et merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation donc cette journée a lieu le
17 octobre elle est née de l'initiative
du père Joseph vrezinski et de celle de
plusieurs milliers de personnes qui se
sont rassemblé sur le parvis des Droits
de l'Homme à Paris en 1987 et cette
journée est officiellement reconnue par
les Nations Unies depuis 1992 alors vous
vous investissez beaucoup par rapport à
cette journée avec l'association ATT
carmonde et vous organisez un événement
à Plaisir oui absolument nous avons
organisé cette année un événement qui
consiste à à montrer que dans le
quartier du valiibou il y a beaucoup de
gens qui sont acteurs de la lutte contre
la misère et pour nous ça passe par une
démonstration d'ordre culturel alors on
va voir une première partie où les
personnes vont être dans un spectacle de
musique spectacle de musique qui est
fait à la fois par les enfants du
Conservatoire de musique de plaisir et
par des jeunes du valibou qui font du
GbE dans une association et en quatre
pôles ils vont présenter
les deux groupes de la musique ensemble
et c'est bien l'idée c'est de montrer
qu'on est ensemble pour avancer dans la
culture donc lutter contre la misère et
puis tout ça cette déambulation nous
amènera dans l'école Brossolette qui est
un lieu où se passeront des comptes hein
dans le milieu de l'après-midi avec
plusieurs compteurs de différentes
associations qui nous ont rejoint pour
pour l'occasion ou de la mairie pour
certains et ces conttes parleront du
vivre ensemble dans dans les
quartiers pour montrer là encore que bon
les choses peuvent se faire autrement
que ce qu'on a l'habitude de dire avec
un quartier qui est souvent un peu
décrié à plaisir alors justement lesons
commencent à 14h30 pourquoi avoir décidé
justement enfin c'est un événement très
festif pour la Journée mondiale du refus
de la misère tout le monde est invité
voilà à se joindre à vous oui voilà
c'est c'est un événement festif parce
que la journée de refus de la misère
n'est pas une une journée triste on veut
là cette année vraiment montrer que on
agit là où on vit c'est le slogan de de
la journée et donc on agit et avec tous
ceux qui sont là et et donc on agit là
cette année avec les les associations
regroupées dans le conseil de quartier
du valiibou une association qui fédère
les associations qui qui sont sur le
terrain et nous à Téd carmonde ça fait
une dizaine d'années qu'on est présent
avec une bibliothèque de rue une
bibliothèque de rue c'est une fois par
semaine pendant 1 heure l'occasion de
lire ensemble avec les enfants des des
des livres pour enfants et et d'être
visible depuis les fenêtres des des
parents de façon à ce que les parents
soient rassurés et que notre présence
puisse être vraiment tout tout à fait
transparente alors je le précise parce
qu'on le voit en image à TD Carmon c'est
une association nationale internationale
et du coup vousz à plaisir ou dans les
Evin vous avez des actions mais il y a
aussi des actions partout dans le monde
et c'est vraiment une journée mondiale
il y a des actions qui vont se se
dérouler partout dans le monde c'est
aussi le but de de faire une journée
comme ça c'est une prise de conscience
pour les citoyens ouais tout à fait je
crois qu'il y a il y a de deux deux
choses qui sont importantes dans cette
journée la première c'est ce qu'on a dit
montrer qu'on agit ensemble et la
deuxième c'est de montrer aux citoyens
que bah finalement il faut faire
confiance aux personnes qui vivent dans
la la très grande pauvreté ou dans la
précarité parce que ce sont elles les
premières en fait qui qui sont à mettre
des des choses en route ne serait-ce que
des petites choses hein au début c'est
des deser son voisin on voit des photos
là qui qui montrent qu'on est sur des
sur du vivre ensemble vraiment au
quotidien et c'est vraiment ça la
première des choses que font les gens
puis après petit à petit euh ils
viennent à à se dire mais on peut nous
aussi apporter des choses pour
transformer euh notre monde et c'est
comme ça qu'on on en arrive à à à
permettre à des gens de donner leur avis
sur des lois et euh ATD carmonde a
beaucoup donné son avis sur la loi du
concernant le RMI de ou justement vous
explique vous agissez vraiment sur des
des problèmes de fond pour faire bouger
les choses en société notamment vous
êtes à l'origine de la transformation de
RMI en RSA c'était du départ au RMI il a
été transformé en RSA après mais c'est
également la CMU qui est quand même très
très importante aujourd'hui qui permet à
des gens de mieux se soigner c'est aussi
le le dallo le droit au logement
opposable même si bon notamment dans un
secteur comme ici où il y a une grosse
pression sur le logement ça marche que
moyen mais bon c'est quand même des
choses importantes qu'on met en œuvre et
puis bon il y a des choses qui qui
deviennent fonctionnelles tout de suite
si jeux dire puis d'autres bah qui
prennent plus de temps actuellement on
est dans des dans des débats
parlementaires qu'on souhaite voir
reprendre du côté de l'Assemblée
nationale sur la discrimination c'estd
dire que la discrimination c'est
vraiment un facteur qui empêche les très
pauvres la discrimination sociale c'est
pauvres d'accéder à leurs droits TD est
vraiment une association qui souhaite
que tout le monde puisse avoir son droit
et sa dignité don le symbole agir tous
pour la dignité c'est difficile
aujourd'hui de mobiliser un peu les
consciences de pousser les gens voilà à
agir à se mobilisé pour une telle cause
je sais pas si c'est difficile si
difficile que ça je pense qu'il y a
quand même beaucoup de gens qui sont
réceptifs on voit bien il y a des bon
même malgré le chômage qui est important
aujourd'hui qui qui plutôt d'habitude
amener les gens à se dire bon benah les
gens qui sont très pauvres c'est pas
complètement de leur faute entre
guillemets là on voit bien que c'est pas
si clair en ce moment mais il y a quand
même beaucoup de gens qui qui ont envie
de faire quelque chose parce que ça les
révolte un petit peu de de voir cette
grande pauvreté qui qui est qui est
présente autour d'eux et je pense qu'il
il y a vraiment beaucoup de gens qui qui
voudraient mais bon après faut trouver
les formes et il y en a beaucoup et
c'est c'est l'objectif de cette journée
montrer qu'il y a plein plein plein de
de formes d'action pour justement
permettre de d'avancer et de proposer
des des choses nouvelles qui qui qui
aide à lutter contre la la pauvreté
collectivement et justement donc voilà
dans ce le cadre de cet événement festif
c'est aussi un moyen pour vous de lutter
contre les clichés par exemple que qui
sont posés sur les gens qui qui sont
dans la pauvreté ouais tout à fait c'est
par exemple je disais là sur la
discrimination c'est on appelle les gens
cassos ils l'entendent partout et c'est
vrai que ça aide pas à se prendre en
main parce qu'on on a tout un poids qui
traîne sur sur soi mais je crois qu' il
y a également beaucoup de clichés les
gens pensent que les les personnes très
pauvres ne contribuent pas à à l'effort
national par l'impôt si on pose la
question à des gens est-ce que les très
pauvres payent des impôts ils vont vous
répondre non or c'est faux puisque quand
même le plus gros impôt qui rentre dans
les caisses de l'État c'est la TVA et je
dire que tout le monde consomme donc en
fait tout le monde participe à la
construction de la société mais il y a
certains à qui on va dire qu'il peuvent
donner leur avis et d'autres ils
pourront pas donner leur avis alors que
moi je pense sincèrement que si les
droits sont respectés pour le plus petit
ils seront respectés pour tout le monde
à plaisir donc vous faites beaucoup
d'actions voilà culturelles est-ce que
vous pouvez nous rappeler voilà
quelques-unes des actions que vous
mettez en place toute l'année parce que
c'est il y a cette journée du 7 octobre
mais c'est un moyen de mettre en lumière
voilà sur une journée l'action que vous
faites tout au long de la vie tout à
fait donc j'ai parlé des bibliothèques
de rue il y en a une à plaisir il y en a
une également à trappe mais il y a
également beaucoup d'actions je pense à
des actions qui sont faites dans le
groupe des des yelines c'est des actions
par exemple de sorti dans des musées de
sorties dans des dans des concerts ou
des choses comme ça par petits groupe et
voilà on prépare ensemble et et du coup
les personnes peuvent accéder à des
choses qu'elles ne peuvent pas faire
autrement et tout ça ça se fait en
partenariat avec des associations qu'on
se cette bonne idée de de vouloir
l'accès de la culture aux personnes très
très démunies donc c'est c'est vraiment
important pour nous parce que je pense
que c'est par la culture que les gens
peuvent rentrer en relation avec les
autres alors même cette journée du 17
octobre vous la faites en partenariat
avec d'autres associations ah oui là il
y a beaucoup beaucoup d'associations qui
sont avec nous puis d'autres qu'on a
qu'on a pas forcément du temps
d'intégrer on regrette bien mais là
c'est bon toutes les associations qui
sont présentes au conseil de quartiers
c'est beaucoup d'associations qui sont
dans le valiibou donc ça ça peut être
des associations en lien avec des
villages d'origine de migrants ça peut
être des associations comme plaisir
vestiaire plaisir solidarité les resto
du cœur sont présents à travers
l'apprentissage de la langue pour des
pour des femmes euh bon il y a vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup d'associations qui
sont concernées et il y a les services
municipaux je parlais du Conservatoire
tout à l'heure mais bon il y a également
la réussite éducative qui nous a donné
un sacré coup de main enf il y a
beaucoup beaucoup de gens qui se sont
fédérés je dirais que la journée elle a
presque dépassé un petit peu ce qu'on
pouvait imaginer et c'est peut-être le
côté positif c'est qu'il y a beaucoup de
gens qui ont eu envie de nous rejoindre
je crois que ça répondait un peu une de
questions que vous me posiez tout à
l'heure je crois qu'il il y a vraiment
beaucoup de gens qui veulent faire
quelque chose pour lutter contre la
misère et là cette journée elle permet
ce ce rassemblement de personnes et et
je pense que c'est c'est ce côté-là qui
est très positif quoi alors ALV si on
n'est pas à Plaisir justement ce samedi
il y a d'autres événements initiatives
dans les evvelines ouais dans les
evvelines il y a d'autresinitiatives il
y en a à la sel saint-clou alors la SEL
saintclou c'est une expo qui est faite à
la MJC qui dure depuis déjà quelques
temps et puis qui va durer jusqu'à
samedi sur les enfants Les enfants du
monde c'est un volontaire d'ATD qui a
pris des des très belles photos et je
pense que ça c'est vraiment quelque
chose à voir dans la dignité je crois
que c'est quelque chose d'important il y
a le chînet où la bibliothèque
municipale a mis en avant un présentoire
où il y a des des ouvrages qui
permettent de comprendre mieux ce que
vivent les personnes démunies et puis
enfin des plusieurs librairies à
Versailles qui euh organisent not
notamment le samedi 17 des des journées
des por enfin des des moments où les
gens vont pouvoir se retrouver autour
des livres et ça tout ça on peut trouver
les renseignements sur le site
refuserlamisère.org donc c'est sans
accent et en un seul mot et on trouve
tous les renseignements que je viens de
donner là alors je le rappelle la
Journée mondiale du refus de la misère à
plaisir c'est le samedi 17 octobre
rendez-vous à 14h30 place roberpierre
d'enton au quartier du valibou et retour
à cour à la cour de l'école Brossolette
et en cas d'intempérie il faut se rendre
directement à à l'école Pierre
brourcelette à 15h30 merci beaucoup
Alain avet d'être venu sur notre plateau
et de nous avoir parlé justement de
cette journée merci et dimanche dernier
l'association média handicap organiser
une nouvelle édition de son triathlon de
l'espérance un rendez-vous dans le cadre
de la Semaine du handicap de Montini le
Bretonneux qui rencontre toujours un vif
succès vous étiez nombreux à venir à
venir relever ce défi proposé parcours
en fauteuil ou encore dégustation à
l'aveugle média handicap a été fondé en
2004 sur l'initiative de l'inimontien
Sébastien proyard lui-même atteint de la
maladie de Charco il entend montrer à
travers son association ce que peuvent
réaliser les personnes en situation
d'icap parmi ses parrains je cite Harry
roselmac ou encore Robert
Hossein et vous l'avez sans doute
remarqué les températures baissent et
vous faites peut-être partie de ceux qui
aiment profiter de cette période pour
aller cueillir et ramasser des
champignons en forêt mais si vous n'êtes
pas un vrai connaisseur ça peut-être
piégeux voire dangereux car tous les
champignons ne sont pas propres à la
consommation Mélanie Pok est allé
récolter quelques conseils pour nous
bonsoir Mélanie bonsoir floral alors la
meilleure période vous l'avez dit c'est
quand les pluies commencent jusqu'à ce
que le gel arrive donc en général de
septembre à décemb à novembre pardon
avec 200000 espèces en région
île-de-fance il y a de quoi faire c'est
pas toujours facile d'identifier les
champignons jérô maffer est membre de
Laan l'association des naturalistes des
ulines il faut apprendre et pour
apprendre on peut apprendre tout seul
c'est plus long ou on peut apprendre
avec des gens qui savent et qui
expliquent c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que
on organise C sorties pour expliquer aux
gens comment faire mais il y a aucune
recette générale et facile qui permette
de séparer un bon champignon d'un
mauvais champignon alors si on décide de
se lancer seul dans la cuillette comment
peut-on savoir si avec notre récolte on
peut se faire par exemple une omelette
alors en cas de doute il faut toujours
se renseigner auprès d'une personne
compétente il peut s'agir d'un
pharmacien certains sont spécialistes
lors de leurs premières années d'études
en général ils étudient ils apprennent à
reconnaître les champignons
l'enseignement a quand même tendance à à
se réduire il ne faut donc pas hésiter à
en chercher un vraiment spécialisé il y
a aussi les associations telles que Laan
elle-même compte parmi dans ces rangs
pardon des pharmaciens passionnés vous
pouvez les
consulter al il y a une autre chose
qu'il faut voir en ramassant les
champignons c'est pas les ramasser dans
des endroits polluer donc il y a des
champignons des prê mais si les prês
sont traités ce qui arrive c'est pas un
bon endroit le long des route c'est pas
très bon parce que pendant des dizaines
d'années il y a eu de l'essence au
plombs et que les bords de route sont
pleins de plombs et que les champignons
ont tendance à ramasser le plomb donc on
peut avoir des champignons bien chargés
en plomb au bord des routes alors vous
demandez à Mélanie est-ce qu'il y a des
lieux à privilégier sur notre territoire
peut-être des petits jardins secrets on
peut trouver les meilleurs champignons
alors peut-être pas des jardins secrets
mais les lieux bien sûr sont multiples
dans les ivelines il y a les bois autour
de Versailles la forêt de Rambouillet ou
encore la forêt de Saint-Germain et une
fois que vous êtes sûr de ce que vous
avez ramassé il faut consommer votre
récolte le soir même ou le lendemain par
contre les champignons s'abîment très
vite et pour les novic est-ce que vous
avez quelques exemples de champignons
qui sont comestibles sans danger alors
justement Jérôme maffer que l'on a
entendu a été faire une récolte le matin
même et dans sa collecte il y avait des
champignons comestibles comme le Bolet à
pied rouge dont la chair bleue très
rapidement alors attention d'autres
champignons ont la chair bleuissante ce
n'est pas un signe de comestibilité on
peut trouver aussi la langue de bœuf qui
est légèrement gélatineuse sur le dessus
et c'est l'un des rares champignons que
l'on peut consommer cru un petit dernier
comestible la coulemelle dont le chapeau
est selon notre spécialiste Jérôme
maffer très bon par contre il ne faut
pas manger le pied ah c'est marrant
parce que ceuxlà je pensais qu'ils
étaient pas du tout comestibles et
justement là on a vu ce qu'on peut
consommer et ceux qui sont toxiques
alors bien sûr il y a aussi dé toxiques
c'est pour ça qu'on en parle dans nos
forêts on peut juste justement trouver
le Paxil enroulé il a longtemps été
considéré comme comestible
malheureusement il y a eu des accidents
mortels parce que c'est un champignon
qui se consomme très cuit alors pour des
questions de sécurité si vous le trouvez
il vaut mieux ne pas le cuillir on
trouve aussi l'amanite phaloïde qui est
sans doute le plus dangereux est très
fréquent il faut savoir qu'entre le 29
juin et le 30 août 2015 l'Institut de
veill sanitaire a répertorié 22 cas
d'intoxication sur toute la France au
moindre doute je vous le répète ne
mangez pas votre récolte si des
symptômes apparaissent vous pouvez
appeler des centres antioison bon on ne
vous le souhaite pas un Mélanie un
dernier conseil ou encore une astuce
pour bien réussir sa cueillette on ça
doit rester un plaisir he la cuueillette
de champignon il faut quand même s'armer
de patience parfois même se lever véau
les passionnés sont très il y a une
grande affluence de passionnés pardon
ils sont très matinaux voilà il ne faut
pas je vous le répète hésiteer à vous
renseigner et un petit dernier conseil
avant de chausser vos chaussures de
marche privilégiez un panier plutôt
qu'un sac pour éviter d'abîer vos
champignons merci beaucoup Mélanie
suivez bien ces conseils attention voilà
à l'intoxication il faut pas ramasser
n'importe quoi on parle maintenant
musique Mélanie vous le saviez peut-être
peut-être vous êtes allé à son concert
mais Natasa Atlas a choisi hier soir les
plonges du théâtre de 550 an nvine pour
présenter les titres de son dernier
album mirade pardon r album pour lequel
elle s'est associé au célèbre musicien
Ibrahim malouf Sephora Namani et Patrick
Jacques de dixmud ont eu la chance de
rencontrer cette chanteuse
regardez Natacha Atlas célèbre chanteuse
d'origine anglo-égyptienne présentait
aux spectateurs du théâtre de
Saint-Quentin en Yveline mardi soir les
titres de son nouvel album myiad Rud
projet pour lequel elle s'est associé à
Ibrahim malouf après un an de
collaboration un album jazz aux
influences orientales est né c'est un
album qui est très influencé par le jazz
on le présente ce soir j'ai trois
chansons en arabe et ça vraiment on
entend le fusion entre l'Oriental et
l'Occident l'occidental mais vraiment
dans le contexte plus
[Musique]
Jaz connu pour ses repris comme mon ami
la rose qui lui ont valu une Victoire de
la Musique en
1999 Natacha Atlas retrouve cette
fois-ci son public en anglais avec de
nouvelles créations expression d'une
intimité profonde un retour sur scène
avec émotion j'ai le
trackb en français j'ai appris
aujourd'hui que en fait un expression
très londonen W c'est
[Musique]
jamais
excitol
nerveuse t les
sentimen même temps avant d'engager une
tournée internationale dernière date en
France ce soir mercredi 14 octobre à
Paris dans le cadre du festival Mama et
son album myiade r sortira dans les bacs
le 25 octobre
[Musique]
prochain
Natacha Atlas et son album merriad r
j'ai réussi à le dire c'est la fin de
cette émission je vous remercie de nous
avoir suivi tout de suite vous avez
rendez-vous avec Sephora Namani pour une
nouvelle édition de kiosque votre
magazine culturel je vous retrouve
demain à 18h pour une nouvelle édition
du 78 le journal je vous souhaite une
excellente
soirée